This is Nanoclaw, a very lightweight
personal AI assistant coming in at
around 500 lines of code and can do
things like connect to WhatsApp, read
your emails, set recurring tasks, and
much more using the power of the Claude
Agent SDK and Apple Containers if you're
on a Mac to keep the whole thing secure.
But how does this tiny assistant compare
to its bigger, more popular alternative?
Hit subscribe and let's get into it.
At the time of recording, OpenClaw
supports around 15 channels, has more
than 45 dependencies, and supports many,
many skills. Manlaw, on the other hand,
has [music] one channel by default,
which is WhatsApp, uses the cell's agent
browser to browse the web, and has
absolutely no configuration file. Yep,
that's right. But its simplicity is what
actually makes it so powerful. Because
the code is small and easy enough for
agents and even humans to understand. If
it doesn't have a feature that you
really, really want, you can just ask it
to build it and it will do it. I've
actually experienced this myself and
I'll show you how it works later on in
the video. But first, let's go through
how to set this up. Actually, let's get
the prerequisites out of the way. I
highly recommend you get a clawed
subscription if you want to use nano
claw since it uses the clawed SDK and
that only supports clawed models by
default. This will make more sense in a
few seconds. If you're installing this
on a Linux machine, make sure you have
Docker installed. And if you're using a
VPS, do all the standard things like
using a nonroot user for the
installation, disabling public access to
SSH and only connecting via tail scale
or an equivalent. You'll also need to
have NodeJS above version 20 installed
and have claude code because you use a
claude code/comand to actually set this
up. And that's why you need a
subscription so you don't waste money
burning tokens through API billing. But
I'm getting ahead of myself here because
you first need to do all these steps
before you get to the claude code/comand
stage, which is pretty self-explanatory
and connects [clears throat] to WhatsApp
using a QR code. From here on, the agent
uses Sonnet by default, which you can
change of course, but keep that in mind.
If you have any issues with the
installation, the creator recommends you
ask Claude's code directly and it will
help you figure out a solution. And
also, if you want to customize your
agent as a slash command to do that, but
again, you can also ask it to do so in
WhatsApp. You also may need to run the
odd npm command and restart the system a
few times. But basically, the setup is
very simple. And if there's a feature
you want that it doesn't say it
supports, you can ask it to add that
feature. For example, here we can see I
asked the agent if it has the ability to
send images. And it replies that it
doesn't have that ability. So if we
scroll down here, I ask it to add the
ability to send pictures. It gives me a
plan telling me what it's going to
change. And I give it permission to do
so. Now it's added image support by
creating a send image tool. So after I
restart the service, I ask it to get me
a random image from Unsplash. Then after
a while, it's able to do that, which we
can see over here. And it's able to do
that multiple times throughout the day.
So I've done it here as well. It's got
me an image of an ocean. And I've also
done it, if we scroll down over here,
too. Now, if I'm being honest, I wasn't
originally sold on Nanoclaw. I mean, it
setup wasn't as smooth as OpenClaw. It
doesn't have a nice dashboard, an
identities file, a soul file, and so
many things that makes the OpenClaw
agent feel so personal. But the
barebones nature of nano claw makes it
so special because it starts off with a
very small feature set and you can ask
the agent to add features that are
specific to you. Meaning somebody else's
nano claw will be very different to
yours and not just have the features
that you want but the code base will be
made to support you as opposed to having
something like open claw which has so
many features but you may only want to
have one or two of them and then you
have this code that exists that you'll
never use. But its architecture also
makes it a bit more secure than open
claw. Not just because of its containers
that have a 5-minute timeout, but also
because it has a smaller surface area
for attacks. A Cisco report revealed
that 26% of all agent skills have
vulnerabilities. And OpenClaw by default
supports a lot of them. Not to mention,
OpenClaw does not run in a sandboxed
environment and has direct access to the
system that it's on. Yes, I would have
loved Telegram support by default and
would love to use models other than the
ones from Anthropic, but the creator
made this originally for themselves and
their own needs, which I completely
understand. But the popularity of
OpenClaw has introduced a wave of
personal AI assistants like Meubot and
Nanobot, which is great, but can only
leads to one thing.
>> Skynet has become self-aware. In 1 hour,
it will initiate a massive nuclear
attack on its enemy. What enemy?